[Music]
britney spears is back
[Music]
dropping her first new song in six years
a duet with elton john
the world is collectively celebrating
britt's long-awaited return after the
pop princess released a remix of elton's
1971 hit tiny dancer called hold me
closer
[Music]
drew barrymore is one of many brit fans
geeking out over the drop it's the first
project britney's put out since her
13-year conservatorship ended we gotta
say we're thrilled for brit and the pop
star sounds like she never missed a beat
on the track
[Music]
elton opened up to the guardian about
his experience working with brit in the
studio telling the outlet it took some
convincing to get the singer to release
their studio record quote she's been
away so long there's a lot of fear there
because she's been betrayed so many
times we've been holding her hand
through the whole process reassuring her
that everything's gonna be all right i'd
be very fortunate enough to be given the
gift of being able to make music and
that is a hell of a gift to be given and
it's a gift britt says she doesn't take
for granted as an artist before the
song's released britney tweeted i'm
kinda overwhelmed
but she felt honored to collaborate with
the pop rock legend tweeting it's pretty
damn cool that i'm singing with one of
the most classic men of our time
[Music]
and seems like the feeling is mutual
elton saying he was ecstatic when
britney agreed to collaborate praising
her on instagram she truly is an icon
one of the all-time great pop stars and
i love her dearly as for how the new
song came together music producer andrew
watt told the guardian brick brought her
a game in her recording session and was
incredibly specific about what she
wanted to do with her vocals she's
unbelievable at layering her voice and
doubling which is one of the hardest
things to do
she really pushed herself vocally
[Music]
we'd say brit and elton just ended the
summer with a smash hit and here's to
hoping there's more britney music in the
works since she did say this i want to
be fearless like when i was younger and
not to be so scared and fearful i choose
happiness and joy today
i'm in the tub right now and i'm about
to go have the best day ever
[Music]
crazy
[Music]